HE WON'T BELIEVE WHAT HE IS NOW
CLAIMING.
WE'LL PLAY ALL OF THAT AND SO
MUCH MORE IN TONIGHT'S BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
BUCKLE UP, THIS IS A BUSY
NEWSNIGHT.
WE START WITH CRUSHING BLOWS FOR
THE RADICAL LEFT AND I DESTROY
TRUMP MEDIA.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ROD
ROSENSTEIN, HAS TOLD THE
PRESIDENT LAST THURSDAY HE'S NOT
A TARGET AND THAT MUELLER
RUSSIAN PROBE OR THE SEPARATE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN.
ROD ROSENSTEIN VOLUNTARILY SHARE
THAT INFORMATION WITH THE
PRESIDENT DURING THIS MEETING AT
THE WHITE HOUSE LAST THURSDAY
AND THIS COMES AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOT DOWN WILD
RUMORS AND SPECULATION THAT HE
WILL FIRE ROBERT MUELLER AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
MONTHS.
THESE DEVELOPMENTS ARE GOOD NEWS
FOR THE PRESIDENT AND A MAJOR
SETBACK FOR THE CONSPIRATORIAL
MEDIA AND LIBERAL DEMOCRATS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
FOR OVER A YEAR, THEY HAVE BEEN
SAYING THAT THERE IS A MAJOR
BOMBSHELL EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
ONE PROBLEM.
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
AND THAT IS CONFIRMED IN FORCE
TONIGHT.
IT'S ALL BUT ONE BIG GIANT
FARCE, TOTAL FABRICATION
CORPORATE CONSPIRACY THEORY,
JUST DESIGNED TO SMEAR AND
DELEGITIMIZE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AS WE ARE SEEING, HE CONTINUES
TO FALL APART.
ANOTHER KEY DEVELOPMENT WE ARE
FOLLOWING TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT
IS ADDING SOME VERY SERIOUS
FIREPOWER TO HIS LEGAL TEAM.
FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI AND TWO OTHER KEY
ATTORNEYS HAVE BEEN ADDED.
RUDY GIULIANI TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THAT HE IS
COMING ABOARD BECAUSE HE HOPES
TO "NEGOTIATE AN END TO THE
RUSSIAN PROBE FOR THE GOOD OF
THE COUNTRY."
AMEN BECAUSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, ALL OF YOU, DESERVE
BETTER THAT MESS.
AS A CRUCIAL MOVE BECAUSE AS WE
HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU,
ROBERT MUELLER, HIS MERRY TEAM
OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS, HE NEEDS
TO STOP THIS EVER-EXPANDING
INSANITY.
RUSSIAN COLLUSION NOW HAS
EVOLVED INTO STORMY DANIELS,
THIS MADNESS HAS TO END.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE FORMER FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE,
HE IS IN SOME SERIOUS LEGAL
TROUBLE.
THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
ISSUED A CRIMINAL REFERRAL FOR
McCABE AFTER FINDING THAT HE
LIED UNDER OATH THREE TIMES IN
AN INVESTIGATION ABOUT MEDIA
LEAKS.
JIM COMEY, ARE YOU PAYING
ATTENTION?
EVEN THOUGH THE EVIDENCE AGAINST
HIM IS OVERWHELMING, MCCABE'S
LEGAL TEAM IS FIRING BACK WITH A
STATEMENT THAT READS, "WE ARE
ADVISED WITHIN THE REFERRAL
WITHIN THE PAST FEW WEEKS,
ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE THE REFERRAL
WAS UNJUSTIFIED.
THE STANDARD FOR AN I.D.
REFERRAL IS VERY LOW."
WE'VE MET WITH STAFF MEMBERS
FROM THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
AND WE ARE CONFIDENT, UNLESS
THERE IS AN APPROPRIATE PRESSURE
FROM HIGH LEVELS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WILL CONCLUDE
THAT IT SHOULD DECLINED TO
PROSECUTE."
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
STATEMENT.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO McCABE
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL, HIS NAME IS
MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
GET USED TO THAT NAME BECAUSE HE
WILL HEAR A LOT ABOUT IT IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
HE INDEPENDENTLY REACHED THE
CONCLUSION ABOUT McCABE LYING
AND HE WAS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THIS PART IS KEY.
MCCABE'S OLD BOSS AND HIS FRIEND
JAMES COMEY, HE IS NOW ADMITTING
THAT HE IS THE ONES THAT KICK
STARTED THE ENTIRE PROBE AGAINST
ANDREW McCABE.
NOT DONALD TRUMP.
COMEY IS ALSO SAYING THAT HE
COULD END UP BEING A WITNESS AND
A POSSIBLE CRIMINAL CASE AGAINST
ANDREW McCABE, HIS NUMBER TWO
AT THE FBI.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> IF THEY ULTIMATELY BRING A
CASE AGAINST ANDREW McCABE,
WOULD YOU BE A WITNESS FOR THE
PROSECUTION?
SPEAKER POTENTIALLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
REPORTING IS ACCURATE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT OF MY OWN
ACCORD.
GIVEN THAT THE IG'S REPORT
REFLECTS INTERACTIONS THAT HE
HAD WITH ME AND OTHER FBI SENIOR
EXECUTIVES, I COULD WELL BE A
BOTANIST.
>> Sean: WHO LOOKS LIKE
McCABE IS CLEARLY CHANNELING
HIS INNER HILLARY CLINTON AND
PRETENDING LIKE THERE'S SOME
CONSPIRACY UP TO GET THIS GUY
BUT IT WAS HIS OWN FRIEND, HIS
BOSS, NUMBER ONE, HE WAS NUMBER
TWO, JAMES, HE IS NOT STICKING B
TWO, JAMES, HE IS NOT STICKING
TWO, JAMES, HE IS NOT STICKING I
TWO, JAMES, HE IS NOT STICKING .
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WEIGHING IN
ON THIS ON TWITTER.
HE SAID JAMES COMEY JUST THREW
ANDREW McCABE UNDER THE BUS.
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ON
OF THEM, GETTING A LITTLE -- A
LOT -- OF THEIR OWN MEDICINE."
SPEAKING TO HILLARY CLINTON,
THIS COULD BE A VERY BAD SIGN
FOR HER AND OTHER OBAMA DEEP
STATE ACTORS.
AS  AS WE EXPLAINED LAST NIGHT,
NEARLY A DOZEN G.O.P. LAWMAKERS,
THEY SENT A CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO
THE DOJ AND THE FBI DEMANDING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO POSSIBLE
CRIMES COMMITTED BY CLINTON,
JAMES COMEY, ANDREW McCABE,
LORETTA LYNCH, PETER STRZOK,
LISA PAGE, AND OTHER OBAMA ERA
OFFICIALS.
IT'S A MASSIVE STORY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SIDE OF YOUR
SCREEN.
THESE ARE THE CRIMINAL CHARGES
THAT THEY ARE RECOMMENDING FOR
JUST JAMES COMEY.
THEY SENT A LETTER TO THE FBI,
THEY DOJ, U.S. ATTORNEY JOHN
HUBER LAYING OUT A PRETTY CASE
AGAINST THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR.
WE'VE WARNED HIM, DON'T WRITE
THE BOOK OF NOT GO ON A BOOK TO
HER.
THEY EXPLAINED HOW COMEY FIXED
FOR CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION,
AGAIN, REMEMBER, HOW LONG HAVE
WE BEEN TELLING YOU?
EXONERATION BEFORE INTERVIEWING
HILLARY CLINTON AT 17 OTHER KEY
WITNESSES.
IT DOESN'T WORK THIS WAY.
THESE LAWMAKERS LAY OUT HOW
COMEY GAVE CONFLICTING TESTIMONY
UNDER OATH, POSSIBLY COMMITTING
PERJURY, AND ADMITTED TO HAVING
A FRIEND WHO LEAKED THE
INFORMATION ABOUT HIS KNOW MOST
OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES," WHICH
IN LIGHT OF THE COMEY MEMOS JUST
RELEASED, HE SAID, I'M NOT
SNEAKY, I'M NOT A LEAGUER.
HE ADMITTED THAT HE LEAKS.
THE LAWMAKERS ARE ALSO REFERRING
CRIMINAL CHARGES TO
HILLARY CLINTON OVER THE SCHEME
THAT SHE USED WHILE FUNNELING
OVER $12 MILLION TO FUSION GPS
THROUGH A LAW FIRM THAT HIRED A
FOREIGN NATIONAL.
NOT SUPPOSED INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTION, CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE IS THE ONE THAT USED AND
CREATED THE UNVERIFIED,
UNCORROBORATED DOSSIER THAT WAS
FULL OF RUSSIA AND RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES AND PROPAGANDA,
ALL IN AN EFFORT TO MISLEAD YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE LEAD
UP TO AN ELECTION.
CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE ALSO BEING
RECOMMENDED BY THESE LAWMAKERS
FOR FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
LORETTA LYNCH THREATENING THE
URANIUM OR AN INFORMANT.
HE WAS ALMOST SHOW WITH
REPRISAL.
ANTI-DROP FBI LOVERS, PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE, THEY ARE
ALSO BEING REFERRED FOR
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THIS CONGRESSIONAL LETTER IS
ALSO ASKING ANDREW McCABE AND
OTHER OBAMA DEEP STATE
OFFICIALS, THOSE INVOLVED IN THE
DOSSIER, THE INVESTIGATIVE FOR
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
FINALLY, JAMES COMEY'S MEDIA
CIRCUS IS TURNING INTO WHAT IS
AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER FOR THE
DISGRACED FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
JUST THIS WEEKEND, COMEY WAS
TRASHING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
CLINTON SYCOPHANT, BFF GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS.
REMEMBER THIS.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS UNETHICAL.
UNTETHERED TO THE TRUTH.
HE'S DONALD TRUMP UNFIT TO BE
PRESIDENT?
>> YES.
NOT IN THE WAY I OFTEN HEAR
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT.
I DON'T BUY THE STUFF ABOUT HIM
BEING MENTALLY INCOMPETENT OR
EARLY STAGES OF DEMENTIA.
HE STRIKES ME OF A PERSON OF
ABOVE AVERAGE INTELLIGENCE WHOSE
TRACKING CONVERSATIONS AND ALSO
WAS GOING ON.
I DON'T THINK HE IS MEDICALLY
UNFIT TO BE PRESIDENT.
I THINK HE IS MORALLY UNFIT TO
BE PRESIDENT.
A PERSON HE SEES MORAL
EQUIVALENCE IN CHARLOTTESVILLE,
WHO TALKS ABOUT ENTRY       ANDT
WHO TALKS ABOUT ENTRY       ANDE
WHO TALKS ABOUT ENTRY       ANDS
WHO TALKS ABOUT ENTRY       ANDW
WHO TALKS ABOUT ENTRY       ANDM
WHO TALKS ABOUT ENTRY       ANDN
LIKE THEY ARE PIECES OF MEAT,
LIES CONSTANTLY ABOUT MATTERS
BIG AND SMALL, INSISTS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BELIEVE IT, THAT
PERSON IS NOT FIT TO BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: AFTER BEING CALLED
OUT RIDICULOUS PETTY, CHEAP
SHOTS, COMEY ALL OF A SUDDEN,
HE'S BEGINNING TO CHANGE HIS
TUNE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU WRITE THAT YOUR
EXPERIENCE WILL GIVE YOU A
LIFELONG HATRED FOR BULLIES.
DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
A BULLY?
DO YOU HATE HIM?
>> I DEFINITELY DON'T HATE HIM.
THERE ARE THINGS HE DOES THAT
MAKE UP UNCOMFORTABLE AND ARE
INAPPROPRIATE THAT ARE IN SOME
WAYS LIKE A BULLY-LIKE BEHAVIOR.
I DON'T HATE DONALD TRUMP.
I DON'T EVEN DISLIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: COMEY CAN'T SEEM TO
MAKE HIS MIND UP.
THEY GUY SPENT THE LAST YEAR
SLAMMING PRESIDENT TRUMP
INCLUDING MOCKING HIS APPEARANCE
IN EVERY WAY IMAGINABLE AND NOW
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
COMEY WHEN HE TELLS US THAT, HE
DOESN'T HATE THE PRESIDENT?
DOES HE THINK WE ARE THAT DUMB?
IS A MASSIVE CONTRADICTION FOR